foreign
up there welcome do you want to share
the commentaries uh the show where we
talk about the other show uh this week
we did Dragon Ball super superhero uh
I'm here with Lon and Danielle we're
gonna give all of our uh deepest darkest
Dragon Ball thoughts and secrets um
we're gonna watch the trailer together
uh pause and we have something else to
say we're going to show deleted scenes
we are going to answer questions so put
those in the chat and then we'll uh
tease you with next week's honest
trailer uh probably a bigger deal than
this week's but you know what I love
dragon ball and
um uh this movie finally came out on um
uh it got released at home
there's a big theatrical hit uh believe
it or not and uh I'll take any excuse to
talk about this show uh or this this
franchise
um but I didn't want to have to re-watch
the entire thing so we're doing this
movie
what are you guys uh what's Your Dragon
Ball history the two of you
um well so I I didn't really get a
Dragon Ball
until you make that joke about the silk
shirts I was dating a silk shirt guy
when I was working at Gameworks and he
was the one that introduced me to uh to
Dragon Ball Z he was like don't start
with Dragon Ball it's too childlike he
says in his silk screened Vegeta shirt
um you want to make sure that you start
with uh you start with Dragon Ball Z and
so I watched a bunch of the Dragon Ball
Z's it didn't do a lot for me in like
the dub but I liked the sub a lot better
which was when I was like oh well good
I'm a true geek now because I'm like
that dork was like I only do Subs I
don't do dubs yeah but but I did I
enjoyed it yeah uh when I was in I never
watched uh I really didn't watch a lot
of anime in high school at all it was it
was like taking off and becoming a thing
when I was in high school but uh you
know like different different groups of
kids than the ones I was hanging out
with but when I was in college I had a
bunch of Roommates who were very into
Dragon Ball Z which was on TV at that
point yeah and so that was really my
first experience of that to to date
basically my only experience with it
until watching this movie so I was
trying I was really trying to like
reapply old Dragon Ball Z knowledge and
like update it to understanding what was
happening in in this in this film that's
fair I watched it on TV after school I
feel like our cameras our camera's
drooping yeah can we get can we get some
help in here we're gonna be the only
ones in the room so there's no one
coming out oh you go I'll I'll be right
back so Dragon Ball uh yeah I watched it
uh after school
um which means that I've only seen like
the Vegeta saga and the cell Saga like
three different times because they would
just play repeats like it would get to a
certain point in the series and then
just reset because I guess they hadn't
finished dubbing them um on Cartoon
Network and they would also do things
like uh remove any blood uh they would
say if they blew up an airplane or a
helicopter they would have someone say I
can see everyone's parachutes they're
okay
but still it was more uh packed with
fighting it was just more colorful than
than American cartoons at the time I was
like wow this just looks different and
they're like there are children fighting
I love this yeah I think that's that's
we stood out I think especially at the
time when we were used to cartoon shows
being pulling their punches well I'm
being very episodic you know it was
always like that that like the 80s
Masters of the Universe Cartoon where
every episode opens with you know He-Man
being like what there's problems in that
Canyon better go investigate and it's
like a new adventure every time and then
Dragon Ball is like the opposite of the
building yeah incredibly long arcs and
it's these these very and I mean they're
they're not nuanced layered stories but
like they're you could say they're
stretched out but they span you know
they're they're very serialized and I
think that was what was so interesting
at the time and so different was like it
does have that sort of feel of a cartoon
but not in the episodic Scooby-Doo way
we were so used to cartoons it was in
this sprawling
sci-fi Multiverse narrative way yeah
that was mind-blowing and then I did
start watching with the the dubs I think
they have great
vocal performances uh I love the voice
of Vegeta The Voice of Goku like it's
hard for me in this case it's hard for
me to do the subs because it's just not
what I it's not my Goku
um but we didn't yeah usually I'm a big
subtitle person for any International
Film or TV show
but yeah Dragon Ball just because I
watched it on TV with the dubbed version
for so long it just feels natural to
watch the dub version for me uh yeah
when I watched the dub of this first and
it was really good again although the
voice acting in this is great let's dive
into this um movie that came out like
seven uh different iterations later but
pretty much the same thing as Dragon
Ball Z uh sort of I I will say one thing
like I I put a bunch of in the notes
that I I don't know how much of it
really came through the trailer like it
does feel very intentionally like
they're kind of leaving some of the
Sci-Fi trappings behind a little bit in
a dime and there's a kind of guy Richie
crime comedy drama Vibe for this one
yeah and there's like humor that
actually like it's that meta humor that
I would normally hate but I think they
actually pull it off pretty well there
is a self-awareness that does not exist
in Dragon Ball no right and certainly
not enough yeah like the classic ones
that I would have seen yeah it's a
little bit of a different vibe yeah it's
very fan service the way that they do it
yeah not like it's apologizing for being
a Dragon Ball movie
um but as a fan I felt very serviced so
let's uh let's watch the Australia
from the studio that brought you
Japanese Spiderman Spiderman
and the franchise
comes a fill with as many plot holes
pacing issues and predictable fights as
the anime but you'll forgive it all
because these characters raised you more
than your parents
hero
strap in for a new kind of Dragon Ball
movie that takes inspiration from
toriyama's colorful Originals shintani's
excellent work on the previous film and
some of the worst looking games on
PlayStation 2. remember cell Shady
to update the visuals for a new
generation because the only thing
Millennials actually killed is 2D
animation
yeah I think there was it was a mixed
bag I don't first of all I don't realize
I don't understand why everyone feels
like they have to be 3D now why do we
have to make everything I think it's
generational for just as for people our
age 3D CG animation always looks a
little weird and cell drawn animation
looks right for younger people it's the
opposite sales run animation looks
old-fashioned and computer animation
looks relevant and like the animation
they expect I will say that it worked
for the most part I think in the uh the
action scenes the the they did a great
job blending the two but I think that
like they just can't resist like having
a completely flat character and then
spinning the camera around yeah it just
looks weird yeah whatever it's gonna
look great it always it reminds me of
whatever an animated cartoon TV show
gets a movie like the Bob's Burgers
movie there's always shots like that and
like the family just standing around but
then we got to do like 3D up and down
around the street and David Fincher
shots like through walls you know yeah
yeah just to prove it's a movie yeah
exactly it's like very like the new toy
syndrome or something where the because
they have a floating camera now they
just gotta fly that thing around like a
drone Like It's gotta be uh like we're
watching red notice over here oh my God
no wait no I mean the gray man like
watching Grace man is the one where it's
like he's on top of the train but then
inside the train all right let's keep
going
last time on Dragon Ball the Red Ribbon
Army sought the wish granting Dragon
Balls to rule the world last time on
Dragon Ball Z the Z Fighters assembled
to save Earth by squeezing their butt
cheeks so hard their hair changed color
last time on Dragon Ball GT we don't
talk about that one but last time
it lasted for like 20 or 40 episodes I
don't remember if it got like two
seasons
um and there was like somebody through
some hilarious mishap or of a wish they
made Goku a kid again sure he's back as
a child for the for the majority of it
and it's like the people the uh the the
the boys who were watching this were
like no he needs to keep getting
stronger he can't I don't know he can't
become a child again but the point of
this show is to watch somebody
somebody's muscles get and hair get
bigger there
[Music]
by the end his hair changed color and he
got stronger again of course and they
they recognized that but yeah we can
only go forward in power I can't go back
their franchise naming scheme for Dragon
Ball is the same as if it was a car
again
yep yep yeah uh yeah it's got the like
it's a Chrysler it's a Dragon Ball XL
touring yeah
the Pontiac Sierra Dragon Ball
all the animation looks like drifting so
oh yeah that's perfect all right let's
keep going fast and furious is next
thanks to the point where you can barely
keep track of who's who wait a second
huge main cast of extended family old
villains keep joining the crew
none of the physics make sense Dragon
Balls Japanese Fast and Furious they're
even obsessed with butts
foreign
[Music]
for a world-conquering army like at the
Sackler family were less evil he'll
recruit Dr hito a child scientist and
the exact midpoint between Gru and
syndrome with the universe's Mightiest
Heroes Goku and Vegeta sidelined by a
missed phone call
thank you all teleporting
literally
the technique hyper child abuse
she's three as he trades
in deadly combat and once again derails
Gohan's normal life to go get beat down
by Androids but hey when the only
competition for best dad is these two
sometimes showing up is all it takes
they closed up The Stepfather he's the
father who stepped up after some
entertaining any warm-ups against
Tweedledum and Tweedle dorg get ready
for the main event against Cell Max a
Kaiju who looks like the Creature from
the Black Lagoon I will say that for
while I did enjoy this movie
they fumbled the opportunity to
introduce like cool new villains well
like though there were no one and two
yeah nah don't need them uh and then
sell max come on I liked I liked one and
two more than sell mad like the the Ben
Schwartz robot guy is is legitimately
annoying it's fun to see him get beat up
yeah I think Tron ralphio is
very much a benchworth sort of type
doing the vocal performance but uh yeah
it's it's a little dull to just have
them fight like a brainless Kaiju
killing machine kind of monster because
this franchise is so much about the the
taunting and the banter and the power
ups and the like you're we're so used to
like Frieza as a villain yeah and like
literally that I think that this show uh
it's the obvious uh but ignored strength
of it is like they make cool looking
characters like they make the they they
make the villains and the heroes like
look really everybody has like a weird
distinctive visual style and they just
took an old one and made them uh made
him more swole and I think like right he
could do better than that well because
because even in the show uh dude is like
well I don't like the old design like we
like superhero designs and that's what's
cool so we're gonna go ahead and
superhero you know make him look like a
superhero it's like I don't know if you
hit that Benchmark yeah he just looks
like he's covered in latex yeah pretty
much uh but you know uh quibble but I
think that that's the cool thing about
the movies is although this one is Canon
or whatever I've lost track some some of
them count some of them don't
um but like it what usually they're
one-offs yeah kind of go crazy this
one's definitely integrated in with the
plot of a season of the show you can
sort of tell there are those like scenes
that don't really link up to anything
else in the movie that are advancing the
show's narrative yeah which I think is
over I don't know well uh I I don't know
keep going from the Gold's Gym he has
only one weakness getting hit on the top
of the head
to stop him Piccolo will have to raise
the Dragon Balls power level in order to
raise his power level and revoke Gohan
into raising his power level before
provoking Gohan into raising his power
level again and raising his power level
again but when Dr hito raises his power
level and magenta raises his power level
and sell backs raises his power level
their new ally must raise his power
level and Piccolo must once again raise
his power level so that Gohan can raise
his power level so hard you guys until
everyone changes color and gets new hair
and explodes in a white hot ball of
pent-up testosterone this whole
franchise is a metaphor for puberty
that's why the theater I saw it and
smelled crazy huh
these things follow such a formula every
single Dragon Ball fight is like
somebody's beating the crap out of
somebody else then they eat they're like
okay I'm now I'm gonna power up now I'm
gonna actually power up then the other
person Powers up and that's kind of even
it's kind of even right uh but then
somebody unveils like oh I've actually
been holding back and they power up and
then they beat the other one down to
within an inch of their life usually the
hero and then they're like I gotta dig
deep I gotta actually power up again and
then they power up to the extent where
there's always the fight the the fights
always end it's like well I just barely
beat them it always ends with them being
so powerful that they're just you know
they're just standing there just Neo at
the end of The Matrix
yeah one hand knocking right it's again
I was gonna I was gonna send another
email but I had already said like four
like how similar distance to Fast and
Furious so I helped out but they kind of
do the same thing there where it's like
they're they're racing and then but
Dom's got to go a little bit harder like
gear like you know like gear a little
bit harder and then they're always
saving the NOS for the very end yeah you
know like oh I've been holding back oh
you lost too soon yeah yeah now you're
drained it is it's a little bit the same
with the taking the beans
I think my favorite one it's not in this
but my favorite example of someone
powering up is in Dragon Ball Z when
Goku just flat out forgets that he's
wearing like a super heavy suit and he's
like oh I could just take this out a
couple times and Gohan does that yeah
they're just like whoops I forgot I'm
I'm wearing a sandbag yeah I'm wearing
my weight training suit so let me take
off my weight training suit now your ass
that's always that's a great move
um yeah take all your clothes off
so I was wearing 60 extra pounds now
I'll really be able to host
commentary keep going
I said it's with your middle finger like
all the very serious anime guys do
whatever oh yeah he's a big fan of that
and just make up all the rules as you go
along
oh right all right
[Music]
isn't here to make new friends it's just
a love letter to the fans who stuck with
it since the Toonami days and an epic
scale animated Cosmic Beatdown never
goes out of style
Goku's got it
storage my hero Academia finally
Musa weenie hugsley son Android
twins
one of us one of us
sell out Peter Pan you see this bad boy
in a silk shirt you know they mean
business that's my Superman doctor robot
lift I love that one
did I just watch a cat God get an
erection with the Jews The Leftovers
Krillin Me Softly do you even lift brawl
and new balls drag race
The Fast and the burliest
yes because it literally happens once a
year for the past 30 years yeah but
don't worry he was training that move uh
the Hyper Beam cannon in secret you know
that's the one move that can blow up an
entire continent he was he was trying to
get a secret there's a couple Islands in
Japan the same place where the eternals
froze that entire God the ocean and
nobody noticed that's where he's been
practicing his particle beam accelerator
yeah yeah in between studying ants or
whatever
yeah whatever he's studying being the
hottest librarian studying ants well
it's good times I I still enjoy the show
for all its silliness um and we do have
uh reading the comments is um Kyle
Herbert uh go check him out at Gohan Vox
at all the all the socials he's the guy
that actually does
um among other things uh next time on
Dragon Ball uh celebrity yeah John hit
him up to read uh read your comments at
the end of this video so do check that
out
um amazing
uh and um yeah thank you all for
watching uh uh our our commentary but we
still have more to do
um also watch our buy the numbers
episode on Vegeta
um where
we actually counted the number of times
he stands up looking down on people like
this
um
former Prince very you know still
hanging on to it how many times he says
uh Prince I am the prince of all Saiyans
um it's a lot uh and it's fight wreck
all sorts of cool stuff if you're a
Vegeta head like me kakarot's number of
kakarots no no no number of kakarots
that would probably be infinite yeah
yeah we couldn't we don't have time
um so yeah check that out on this very
same channel and let's see what we cut
from this episode
story help my son's a nerd do not pass
Gohan the great saiya man there's
clobbering time he's an angry elf the
incredible sulk call me by your Namek
the Green Gob the orange Goblin Uncle
Piccolo could throw an Android over them
mountains
hey I'm plotting over here he noticed
despicable we cookies and scheme Mew and
Mewtwo going number two I just picked up
some new Intel on who the villains are
are we the baddies boss frog Maxell
battery
Matilda train and gain
VeggieTales smack a lot How to Train
Your Dragon Balls lean in we got it
just a slob like ABY Russ hell no kitty
I wonder why Broly doesn't talk much in
the all right and Rhonda Grant wish and
Dragon Ball Ron
rage
Super Smash Brothers
wild speed superhero
that's the Japanese title of Fast and
Furious
um Good Times really enjoyed Dragon Ball
Ron
hi I'm Dragon Ball raw that was one for
me
um so let's go into the uh into the Q a
and this is an interesting question off
the bat by uh Evan Jay pretzer um I grew
up on Toonami like anyone and man that
raised instead of your parents line hit
so accurately uh oh sorry sorry Evan a
question for the crew and the chat is
there a certain thing which did that for
you I mean for me look my parents raised
me but that was like home from school
watch Dragon Ball Z like that was just
part of your routine so what was your
first thing back from school or or
whatever like raised you uh uh TV show
wow uh I'm trying I'm trying to even
think of like what the thing I thought
I'd rushed home to watch her yeah you go
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles was a big
one yeah uh turtles was one that I like
raced home for uh you know uh your
Pokemons your uh your Mighty morphins
that power ranged
um what else was some of the big ones
and then also when they would do like
like you would have a Save By the Bell
or something that would come on like at
night but I would say mostly like
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles when that
came on because they I think they had
that on for like a block oh and Simpsons
we run duh yeah I love Simpsons reruns
for sure love Turtles and I I feel like
I already kind of kind of threw this out
there like I I was a big He-Man kid I
loved Masters in the universe when I was
a young kid so that show for sure was
like uh I feel like was that Saturday
morning key man was a morning card I
feel like that was a morning Saturday
mornings but whenever it was I that that
was like appointment TV for me as a kid
for sure I also like Transformers a lot
and for me the the nighttime viewing
night time being 7 30 was he was beepus
and Butthead oh yeah um but then yeah
yeah later because too many kids were
watching but I was I was already
12 13
so like I was already a little older
right I had another so I was I was
getting into the liquid TV MTV era when
I was way too young
um yeah it's the same thing with me and
my older sister that's why our nicknames
are being Butthead or Wilson Munch she's
in my phone as wuss I think I'm in hers
as much
uh it's kind of dovetailing off this is
a Trevor copter ass is there another
series a western animated one or an
anime that you'd want to see come back
like Dragon Ball do the Dragon Ball
super if you don't know there was like a
10-year Gap where there was no Dragon
Ball and then they're like you know what
we're getting the gang back together
we're doing it with another series we're
picking up with these characters uh a
little bit later
I I really I gotta be honest like anime
shows are are kind of a blind spot for
me I've seen a few I like that you know
this one I've seen I've seen Cowboy
Bebop I've seen some Pokemon but
it's a rare anime show that I've watched
like consistently I guess I guess a
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure I've seen some
of those okay for those Seasons yeah you
know what I'm gonna go with Western
animation I'm gonna go with Western
adult animation I want to know what the
critic is up to
bring the critic back with just a
YouTube channel like with a V2 Birds now
like oh my God so much more like like
mainstream now those ideas by the rights
to the critics yeah
um yeah I'll throw an anime out there
Hajime no IPO was a was a boxing anime
that I watched that uh was really good
and then it came back but it was like
the entire thing was a the the new
season that came back was a flashback
series to like a very hyper nationalist
World War II Japan story I was like well
join the modern era like let's let's do
another thing we don't need to do that
one
um yeah
um I think I believe I'm probably
butchering the name because I haven't
watched it in a while but I think it's
kanikoman which is uh a wrestling anime
and that was one where there was the
original 80s version and if you had like
the those little muscle men that were
kind of like army men but wrestlers
those were actually based on that series
but then they came over to the US and
they did another version later where it
was like his son is now like a wrestler
who put on his mask and
um and they brought that back and that
was still even like maybe 10 20 years
ago so I'd love to see them do another
one of those since they already had that
generational thing going awesome all
right yeah sweet
um I want to bring back also for Western
animation I want to bring back uh Pro
Stars which was Michael Jordan Bo
Jackson oh sure yes
honestly every 80s or 90s cartoon that
was spun off from like a wrestler or an
athlete bring all those bring them all
back I want to see like that that Mr T
cartoon show again
these days yes oh Hammerman
yeah I still know that whole theme song
it's bad yeah uh let's see so uh Marcus
why asked was every fight in Epic voice
guy script no we just looped it I think
it uh we only had to say fight four
times I was like it's funnier if he'd
keep saying it uh there's so much
fighting we could have kept that going
yeah it was uh that is actually cut down
by half yeah um so and then oh James
Bond has a good one what anime Special
fight move would you want to be able to
do is there any any uh any anime
techniques you wish you had the Naruto I
want to do the Naruto sexy Jutsu where I
thought you were gonna do the narrative
Running Oh I wanted to run and have it
actually make me faster that'd be fun uh
I I in you remember ninja scroll sure in
ninja school he's got that staff with
like the wire weapon in it that he could
like fling at people like that's pretty
badass I would like to have a ninja
scroll type weapon um yeah I Avatar
doesn't really count but I guess I would
really like it if I could just like
float on a cloud of parts or air or
whatever that was that would be cool
sure so this will be our final question
and also related
um uh Johanna Stromer asks what are your
favorite animes and can you recommend
some and like none of us are experts
we're we're gonna be we're gonna level
with you but I did watch a lot of baki
the grappler on Netflix oh yeah
I feel like Dragon Ball Z but like uh
mixed with like Tom of Finland like uh
it's just insane yeah I mean my starter
anime show which I feel like is the best
place if you want to dip in the toe and
you're a western person who hasn't tried
it before is Cowboy Bebop I think that
really is the essential like there's
movies and stuff like Akira goes to the
show like all the miyazakis like a lot
of classic but I think in terms of like
what anime is all about and the tropes
and like as a genre in addition to as a
style or whatever like I feel like
cowboy boots is a logical place to start
yeah also and and you know what Sailor
Moon is still dope when you go back and
watch it Sailor Moon is one where you
have to go back and watch the original
Japanese one because like even though I
because I also have like a lot of uh
love for the
um a love for the dubbed ones because
that was what was over here in the U.S
it's just a different show like those
girls ain't cousins
there's a new there's a new tri-gun
series too isn't there I like it I
remember like that original one and I
feel like there's like a remake or a
reboot that's happening now that would
be like with the there's like the Vespa
and the girl with the bass uh fully
Cooley or FL oh FLC yes yes yes yes yes
yes I like that one but we don't know no
I'm the wrong we don't know more than
you do viewer I'm sure you could
recommend more to us than yeah because
you know people love that that that
attack on Titan one that I don't know I
watch it for a season it's good but by X
family is a big one now yeah we have a
lot of catches yeah I never got into my
hero Academia what's the one
um I I you guys are gonna know it
because it's one of the biggest ones but
it's the one where like they all form a
giant robot together Ultron or yeah well
that is Voltron or gun yeah
yeah they did
some recent series of Gundam which was
really fun oh there's also one punch man
which is
hilarious yeah all right there you go
we've named every anime which was just
on Hulu I liked that one too nice
um all right so hopefully we've given
you something to check out but give us
more to check out because we we don't
know nothing
[Music]
um
please join us next week uh where
something we know a little bit more
about
um only a little yeah they don't over
promise yeah
which is
um I'd say it's uh it's more of a
wasteland that we're uh next week then
um then a cool sci-fi thing but you know
what we're gonna get through it together
and that's your clue okay okay that's a
clue uh for next week come join us again
uh watch on us trailers watch by the
Numbers watch all the just watch the
just stay watching shows keep watching
recommended next videos until we're back
next week and we'll see you then thanks
for watching bye-bye
right on time
[Music]